[music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> So I developed a well a very strong
uh I can almost say hate hat towards
this god. And I think it had a lot to do
with me becoming an atheist. It became
easier for me just to negate him and get
rid of him out of my life and say he
didn't exist. So that's how I became an
atheist in the fullest sense. And I
said, "God, if you exist,
then reveal yourself to me.
>> [music]
>> Welcome friends to the Belt of Truth
podcast. I'm your host Scott Ritzma for
a very special edition of our program.
Our guest is going to be the one that
needs no introduction in this case,
Walter Vice and his co-host Martin
Smith. We're going to be discussing
Walter's testimony, Professor Vice's
testimony from atheist to to Catholic
for a short time to Bible believing
Christian. And before we begin and bring
our brothers up, I want to uh remind the
listeners, those who are not aware, I'm
sure the vast majority of you already
aware of their work, but you can find
them at Clash of Minds, and we'll put
the link in the description of this
video, so you can follow their work over
there. But let's begin with prayer.
Father in heaven, we thank you so much
for an opportunity to share what you've
done in in one man's life. It's the
servant of the Lord that that so many
have found enlightenment and Bible truth
through on online. And we just thank you
for your work in these last days. We
want to have your name glorified and
your truth vindicated. And I pray that
every listener who is engaging with this
content that they would encounter Jesus
through this video and see the urgency
of the times that these are times which
call for us to make decisions for you.
And we pray this in Jesus name. Amen.
Welcome brothers. It's very good to have
you on the program and and where are you
streaming in from right now?
>> We're in a town called Hutsprit
which translated means Hat Creek.
because somebody was fishing at this
little creek and his hat fell into the
water. So they called it Hat Creek. So
that's our town and we're very close to
the Creger National Park. So uh we have
some game farms around us all the way
around us and we hear the lions roar at
night.
>> Wow, that's special. I've never been to
South Africa. I need to come sometime
and it's good to be speaking with the
two of you. Just yesterday and this
morning, first time that I've had the
chance to communicate with you too and
it's a blessing and a delight and I I'm
looking forward to digging into the
testimony of of Walter on the right
there, Martin on the left introducing
you to our our viewers. But um there's
been some recent really rumblings within
Christianity over the past week or so. A
major video has come out and I wanted to
get you guys reaction to that first
before we do the testimony. It was by a
very popular evangelical Christian named
Kirk Cameron who was a former actor in
sitcoms and has become a ve very
well-known and influential name in
Christianity. He came out with a video
and really departing from the majority
view in evangelical Christianity on the
nature of hell. and saying he's leaning
against the view that teaches the
eternal conscious torment of the wicked
for eternity. That was no small
controversial stance to take, was it?
I'm interested in getting both of your
reactions to that Kirk Cameron video.
>> I found it fascinating.
Uh the fact that they were leaning
towards a view that we are more
acquainted with is interesting. But I
also found it interesting how they tried
to uh justify this kind of punishment
because of the position of God and his
authority.
So that made it made it interesting
because they left the back door open
that perhaps there would be an eternally
burning hell where God would punish
people for all eternity on the basis of
a short period that we spend on earth.
>> Yeah, I think it was a good um place to
get at on their own. Yes. where they
where they got to without anybody
influence and now they actually open and
now it's time to really give them the
>> yes
>> tell them you are basically there
because they've got a real backlash from
other evangelicals now I mean I've seen
Stu Peters quite
what is Stu Peters
>> probably Stu Peters
>> but a lot of them have been making
videos now against Um good
>> and and they were quoting the book of
revelation
which uh taken in isolation has some
tricky texts to deal with in this issue
and I can understand their strugg
struggle and their thinking and having
been brought up in the mure in which
they operate I can understand the
confusion and my heart goes out to them.
Yeah, they've made some good progress in
this video for sure from one direction
to another. The way that I put it is
they're they're they're like 95% of the
way there. And I was curious how you
guys felt about that. That door was left
open and there well, we don't know about
Revelation 14 and rich man and Lazarus
seems to this and that. And I had the
thought, you know, it's only a matter of
time before these brothers open a
concordance and look up every verse in
the Bible that uses the word forever and
then import that understanding into the
Revelation 14 text. But um how would you
help them out with that difficulty that
they've encountered? Well, you know, we
are going to talk about testimonies a
little further on in our discussion
and I thought perhaps, you know, if I
gave my own walk in that particular
sphere of thinking, it might help
people. You see, I grew up in a house
where my father was Roman Catholic and
my mother was Protestant. She was a
Lutheran.
And uh in those days because I have many
gray hairs as you see
uh that was the days before Vatican 2.
And so the official
way in which the doctrine of the
Catholic Church was portrayed at that
time.
it was if you were not a Catholic then
unfortunately you were doomed to this
eternal hell no matter what your
circumstances were.
So as a as a young boy in the school, I
received my religious instruction from a
very well-meaning nun who had uh of
course their doctrines at heart.
And she probably had a soft spot for my
mother too who was dying of cancer and
was very concerned that she not being a
Catholic was going to suffer the
consequences of eternal hell.
Now, as a young child, this didn't go
down well with me because uh
to every young boy, of course, his
mother is very important. And this
concept was to me one that alienated me
from the God that uh she was telling me
to embrace.
So I developed a well a very strong
uh I can almost say hatred towards this
god because being young you do not
necessarily separate doctrine from
reality.
And I think it had a lot to do with me
becoming an atheist because rather than
deal with this concept of having such a
god, it became easier for me just to
negate him and get rid of him out of my
life and say he didn't exist. That of
course didn't get rid of any
spiritualistic leanings
because there were obviously phenomena
that I was accustomed to that showed
that there was something there on the
other side communicating with spirits
etc etc.
So the only thing that I totally cut out
was this concept of a god who was
wrothful and was going to uh punish you
for all eternity on the basis of a short
life even if it was a good life that you
led never having a fly as was the case
with my mother.
And I find it interesting that people
that were basically like me in this
world and one of the top evolutionists
in the world of course is Richard
Dawkins. And he wrote a book called The
God Delusion.
And if you read that book, you will see
that most of his animosity
stems not from what the Bible teaches,
but from what the church teaches. And
one of the doctrines that he really
abhored was the doctrine of hell. And he
even made a snide comment that he wished
there were a hell where some of these
people including the nuns he mentioned
in that in that book where they could
suffer the eternal consequences of hell
because of teaching such doctrines. So
I'm not the only one who has been
alienated from from embracing God as a
loving deity. I believe that there are
millions in the world that uh feel the
same. And when I listened to that
discussion,
uh, it seemed very clear that these
thoughts were running through the minds
of these people as they were trying to
collate the concept of a loving God who
was willing to die for you on a cross
with one who is so vengeful that he
would make you suffer to that extent.
And and the beauty of of the gospel is
that you don't have to uh distort the
scriptures in order to come to a better
understanding.
You have to understand the nuances and
how to interpret scripture. You see,
scripture moves from the the clear and
the understandable
to that which is couched in types and
symbols and has to be interpreted.
And you can never interpret from the
complex allegorical
uh way of presenting something to the
simple. You have to go from the simple
to the complex. And the Bible gives us a
clue as to how to do that. It says um
here a little, there a little. You have
to study this verse and compare it with
that verse. And you have to, as you
mentioned in the beginning, Scott, you
have to get a complete picture on the
doctrine of eternity.
May you live forever was a constant
thing that the that the Hebrews referred
to when they spoke about their kings.
Obviously, they knew that that king
wasn't going to live forever and ever,
that there would come an end to his
reign.
But the the idea of this forever was
until it has come to fruition or
completion.
And once you start understanding that
and you look at the parallel of Jeremiah
for example who talks about the
unquenchable fire that will never go out
and then proceeds to the point where he
said this was fulfilled when um
Nebuchadnezzar
destroyed Jerusalem. Well that fire is
not burning anymore. So how could this
fulfill the unquenchable fire that would
never go out? Well, it wouldn't go out
until it had done its job. That was the
point. And then also the doctrine of of
death or uh resurrection and soul sleep.
These are concept that the Christian
world has been wrestling with for eons.
And the reformers uh Luther, Tindle,
Fritz, all of them by studying the
scriptures, obviously they did because
they translated them, came to the
conclusion that death was a salt sleep
awaiting a resurrection.
So once you put all of those ideas
together, then you can understand uh
what God is all about.
Now I don't want to you know dominate
the discussion here but when we talk
about the fairness of God then it's very
important to understand that God never
deceived anybody.
He was upfront from the beginning. He
said the day you eat of it you will
surely die. So when he created man, he
placed him under a jurisdiction and
under a law and he said the day you
transgress that you will forfeit the
right to life. So I give you the choice
because God is all about freedom of
choice. So he was very upfront. There's
a conditionality
that is attached to life and the
conditions are wrapped up in the
government and in the requirements of
God in order to have an ordered society.
One where there will be mutual respect
for everyone and not one that runs on
the basis of this world for example. And
therefore God was very upfront and said
these are the conditions. You forfeit
the conditions and you forfeit the
privileges
when you transgress and choose not to
follow these precepts.
And therefore God is in the business of
giving us a choice. And the final choice
as to whether we exist for eternity or
whether we do not exist for eternity
rests with us.
Absolutely. Martin, what do you have to
add to that? I find that to be the most
beautiful picture of God's character
allowing freedom. um not bringing
excessive punishment beyond what is
necessary, but it it it it draws us to
him. And folks, you just heard Walter
Vice say what drove him to atheism as a
as a child was this very issue, this
very doctrine. And when Kurt Cameron
said toward the end of his video, "This
is about God's character," that touched
my heart. Because that's part of my
journey as well, coming into the truth
because of knowing who God is. Martin,
what do you have to add to this? Well, I
can just maybe add a little bit on
in 2015,
I actually um attended me and my wife
I've attended a lecture a lecture series
of Walter and the Sabbath and everything
that was presented there was easy to
digest and easy to accept for for us.
But the one thing that actually was the
little thing that kept us the busiest to
overcome was the the soul sleep, the do
this doctrine. And once I understood it
and even my wife, we had such a relief.
>> It's like a weight falls from your
shoulders.
>> It's just amazing. But if I may, can you
maybe just explain in short the Lazarus
situation because a lot of people get
stuck with that one. Yes. Well, you see
the the the story about Lazarus is a
story that is interpreted as a reality.
But obviously what Jesus was addressing
was
the misconception
about the afterlife. It it dealt again
with the question of of death and a
resurrection.
Will there be a resurrection? And the
Sadducees, they denied the resurrection.
In fact, they probably believed like
most of the evangelical world believes
today that there is a spirit realm in
which you move when you die and that
there is no re resurrection.
The Pharisees on the other hand believed
in death and resurrection. And Paul
clearly says as regarding this doctrine
that he is a Pharisee, he believes in
death and in a resurrection.
And blessed are those that have part in
the first resurrection.
And of course, if you believe in the
spirit world, then you also believe that
there is some form of communication
possible with that spirit world. And the
scripture clearly says in Job and in
many other places that when you're dead,
then you know absolutely nothing. Then
your thought processes stop and there is
no praising of God. There is no no
thinking with God. And as Job says and
Ecclesiastes as well, there is no
returning to the place where you come
from to the home. You're not going to
watch your children messing up. You're
not going to see any of that. So the
Sadducees had this idea
and they of course believed that uh
because they were the children of
Abraham
that purely by lineage they were saved.
>> They were the chosen people. So God
takes this thinking of theirs and Jesus
turns it on its head.
Instead of the rich man who in their
thinking was rich because he was blessed
by God going straight to the eternal
bliss, he goes to uh this bad place
which they also obviously with Greek
philosophy all around them thought was a
place of punishment.
So that turns their doctrine upside
down. And Lazarus who was full of sores
represents the pagan world that is full
of sins and is trying to find some
crumbs that is spiritual crumbs from the
rich man's table. But he is very selfish
because he believes basically that he
alone is chosen. And by the way that
doctrine isn't dead. It's alive and well
in in Calvinistic thinking today
>> in many parts of the world.
And here's this rich man and he's up uh
he's down in this uh terrible situation
and the poor man is sitting on on the
lap of Abraham
and then he prays and he says, "Father
Abraham," this is now the rich man.
"Father Abraham, please will you, you
know, alleviate my suffering over here?"
Now firstly, you're not supposed to pray
to the dead. And Abraham at that stage
was dead, wasn't he? So he was actually
transgressing a very distinct law that
is written in the Torah.
So you're not supposed to do that. So he
was addressing an ancestor rather than
addressing God in his requests. And that
is being done in the world today as
well. Right? Don't they speak to saints
and to departed spirits and uh ancestor
worship and all of these things? This is
prevalent in the world today.
Finally, he says to him, "Well, what if
I send him to, you know, your brothers
here on earth and warn them from the
fate to come?" The Bible had already
said in Job, never again will they
return. And so, the answer is, you know,
you didn't believe the law and the
prophets. How are you going to believe
someone that comes from the spirit world
and tells you these things? So, in other
words, he was taking their thinking
pattern, turning it upside down, and
negating
what they were telling the world. So,
this is not this is not a story based on
reality. This is like an allegorical
tale where he takes the doctrine of the
day, which is exactly the same doctrine
as we have in the world today, turns it
upside down and takes them back to the
scripture. That's where your answer
lies. Not in your philosophies, not in
your traditions, not in your false
theology. Go and study the word. And
that cannot be taken as a story of
reality in that sense. So
>> yeah and and and also just a small short
um statement
if people are after they die in an
eternal either hell or heaven if the
hell is also eternal that then the
devil's first lie is true.
>> Yes. Then you are immortal.
>> Then you are immortal. So even if you're
immortal in death, then his lie in the
beginning for with Eve is true.
>> Now this this word in the Old Testament
in the Hebrew shaw actually means grave.
And in the the New Testament,
it mean it's translated hell, but in
many cases it's also translated grave.
This hadess. So what is it? Is it is it
now a grave or is it a fiery inferno?
The word they get confused with isa
and henna is a place of of fire and
burning. But it refers to the fire that
comes down from heaven and burns forever
and ever until it in other words until
it has brought to finality what it was
designed to do. the obliteration
of those that opposed God from the
beginning because the other portions of
the scriptures tell that that they will
assume away. They will cons be consumed
like and be smoke. Never will they be
anymore.
So there are very clear texts which
explain what that
final destruction by fire that Peter
refers to when he says Sodom and
Gomorrah serve as an example of those
that will suffer the consequences of the
eternal fire, the extent, the finality
which is for eternity. In other words,
they will be as though they never were.
And God will wipe away the tears because
there will be tears even in that
process. But it is the only guarantee
that sin will not raise its head again.
>> That's beautiful. God will bring an end
to sin and suffering. He will wipe away
every tear. There will be no more
crying. Um, it was so liberating to me
when I encountered in the Bible the word
forever means, like you said, Walter,
for the totality of the time period in
question. And so, the devil's going to
be brought to ashes. The Bible says he's
going to burn forever till he's ashes.
He's going to burn for the totality of
the time period in question, as will the
wicked, who will be ashes under the
soles of the feet.
>> Never will you be anymore.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's very clear. And I
liked what you said about take the clear
and the simple texts and then use those
to understand the allegorical. I mean,
it was so liberating to me when I was
like, oh, the parable of the rich man
and Lazarus, it's a parable,
>> right? Yes.
>> And and there are parables in Judges
where the trees are talking and we don't
take from that a doctrine about trees
talking, right? So it troubled me a
little bit in that Cameron interview
where I mean I God bless these brothers
but when they said there seems to be
some evidence on both sides I was
wincing and I was like no the Bible
doesn't contradict what appears to be
evidence on the other side is not it
just needs to be understood with a clear
and simple Bible study. You know what we
should put links in the description to a
Bible study on that just a memo to that
editor. We're going to put that in and
then folks can walk step by step through
all these texts that you're alluding to
because the Bible is full of these. This
is not a difficult confusing uh issue.
It's very clear. You just have to study
it through. Well, let's get into the
testimony. We could talk. Give give us
one last thought on this and then go to
>> I have three lectures on it in the total
onslaught series. The one is called the
mystic realm of death which deals with
all of those verses in the Bible. The
other one is called uh history's coming
climax. What happens at the coming of
Christ? And the third one is the final
combination, the long awaited
millennium. If you look at those three,
then you get the concept of what happens
in death, what happens at the second
coming, and what happens after the
millennium and during the millennium.
And that should put those those verses
into context.
>> Great. We're going to link to those. And
you don't I don't know if you know this.
We've never spoken about this. 20 years
ago, do you guys remember something
called Google Video before YouTube was
the big thing. A friend of mine, I was
exploring the unseen side of history. I
was a history teacher and trying to
understand what's really going on in the
world. And a friend of mine said,
"There's this guy you need to look up.
You got to watch his videos, Walter
Vice." I'm like, "Okay, I don't ever
heard. Let me let me look it up." So, I
found this series, Total Onslaught, on
Google video, that old frame from about
2005 when I watched your series, and
that was one of the first speakers that
I've heard from this biblical
perspective that we're discussing here,
and it was pivotal in my journey. So, I
just praise God for that series. We're
going to link to that for sure. And, you
know, you already began a little bit
with the testimony talking about that
very sad experience as a child. I mean,
people hear you talking about that and
it brings tears to the eyes to think
about this little child whose mother is
sick and dying and the religious
teachers are saying that she's going to
be burning. I don't even want to say it.
It's just such a diabolical view of God.
It drove you into atheism. So, where did
you go from there? Um, did you did you
go to university ended up as a
professor? But tell us the steps that
that came out of that childhood into
atheism.
Well, as a consequence of this childhood
trauma, the interesting thing is I was
at a school that was basically it was a
German school. So the the majority of
the learners were Lutheran
and there was a small group of Catholics
who received religious instruction from
from that quarter. A nun came to the
school to deliver that. And when I
protested this teaching as a child and
at one stage
was I admit very obnoxious in the class.
I actually tore up the catechism
and said I wanted nothing to do with
this god. I was probably about 10 years
old, I think, and I was thrown out of
the class and had to sit in the
courtyard. And the Protestant principal
would find me there and ask me what I
was doing outside. And I would, in not
very kind words, [laughter]
tell him what what the lady had done to
me and thrown me out of the class. But I
didn't give him the details. And so
obviously I was the culprit. And so I
was thrashed by him on a on a regular
basis because in those days, you know,
thrashing was part and parcel of the
upbringing in a school. Did you still
experience that, Martin?
>> Yes, I had quite a bit of thrashing.
>> Did you have your posterior modified on
a regular basis?
>> A regular a daily basis basically.
[laughter]
>> Well, it was very very part and parcel
of South African school system at that
stage.
So anyway, after all of those
modifications, I not only developed a
resentment for religion, I re developed
a resentment for school
>> and to to such a point that they were
going to expel me as a useless scholar
[snorts]
because I rebelled. I refused to study
and uh you know would return zero grades
unless au teacher was kind to me then I
would have very good grades
but the system was [laughter] was so
rigged that if I got a good grade I got
thrashed because I didn't have good
grades in the other other ones. So they
said oh so you can get good grades so
we're going to thrash you because you're
not getting good grades in the others.
you're obviously there's something wrong
with you. So I developed a a resentment
for school as well. And uh eventually
when it got to the point where they said
all right then you are not going to go
to school anymore. We're going to take
you out of school and you're going to
learn some trade somewhere.
And uh that was good for me because with
my by then welldeveloped rebellious
nature if somebody said A then I was
going to do B.
So they said no more school for me. So
that for me meant now I will go to
school.
>> Oh you're not going to do good.
[laughter]
>> I'm going to do this now. So I
approached an uncle of mine who was a
headmaster in another school.
He didn't see his way clear to take me
into his school. I was too rebellious.
So he arranged for me in another school.
There I also got into trouble. But uh
that doesn't matter. Eventually I did
pick up my grades and went to university
and became acquainted with science and
particularly
zoologology the evolution theory and I
became a physiologist
and uh that was then a large part of my
career but uh the education that I got
was steeped in evolutionism. So
obviously I embraced it as my answer to
the God question
and I could happily
uh negate him through the theory of
evolution. So that's how I became an
atheist in the fullest sense and a an
evolutionist a militant evolutionist
much in the line of Richard Dawkins. H
well the Lord had plans for your life
beyond that and my understanding is it
you met a girl and it was your
father-in-law and some of his
experiences in the spiritual realm that
started to make you question some of
these atheistic assumptions.
>> No, it never it never threatened my
atheistic assumptions.
uh God didn't exist, but there was some
supernatural
world out there, but there wasn't a a
central being that was God in in an
essence. The second lie of the serpent,
you shall be as gods. We actually were
gods and through our divinity created
the reality that is around us. All that
we had to do was discover the spark of
the divine within humanity. That's
basically new age philosophy,
uh, Blavatski philosophy, theosophy, and
and all of those directions. So, I
embraced that and atheism in the in in
the sense of a divine independent
personage called God.
That's an important distinction that the
existence of the dark oult, which I I
would like for you to tell us about that
from your father-in-law's experiences,
that doesn't teach us Bible doctrine.
That doesn't teach us about God, the
creator God, and his love for us.
>> Definitely not. By the way, Darin
belonged to spiritualistic societies.
Darin took part in seances.
Darin experienced occult phenomena.
So he was wellversed in in these kinds
of things as well and he negated uh the
the presence of a distinct deity such as
God through that way of thinking. Yes.
>> So eventually your father-in-law moves
moves in or near your family. Um tell us
about that family's background and how
that brought some unwelcome things into
your own family as a young parent. Yes,
he he was uh very much involved in the
rise of the new age movement and uh they
brought out a magazine which was called
inner space
where they discussed the occult
phenomena. He also at a stage worked for
a newspaper and was responsible for
following up on occult phenomena in the
country which are which is very real in
this country. If we had to tell some of
the stories nobody would believe us as
to what goes on in the spirit realm.
>> But maybe you can tell just one
>> small one. Oh, I can tell from his
story. But I mean in the African Oh,
>> in the African millia or the African
drum rituals.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Which are basically like voodoo rituals
where you you call up the spirit world
and you actually
uh invite them to take you over.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You can see that in most of
the African Yes.
>> ancest religions have that. But in in
the in the theosophical world, it's a
little bit more uh scientific and
eventually you end up with things like
Scientology
where you learn to clear your karma
and once you have cleared your karma
even of previous lives socalled
then you
get to a position which they call clear.
And once you are clear then basically
you are divine.
>> And so there was a book written by it's
a chneled book written by Helen Shookman
and uh it's about how to perform
miracles. It's actually called a course
in miracles. And basically in that in
that book Jesus would be someone who had
achieved this clear position.
And therefore anybody who has achieved
that as well can be as successful as he
was Martin in in um
>> in performing miracles. So basically you
become God. So I was on on that level of
thinking. I studied the theosophical
works. Uh I I read Blavadski. I read
Alice Bailey's books. I read uh the book
Bridges and many of the of the occult
writings. Later I became involved in in
the writings of the secret societies and
they're so intermingled
that eventually when you go down to
their roots you find that they're
actually one in the same thing.
just looking at the the issues from a
different perspective or coming from a
different angle. The one is more in the
spirit world and the other one is more
in the implementation
in the political and uh you know the
rest of the entertainment world and how
to bring this message across and they're
doing a great job of course with
Hollywood and all of them involved and
eventually through my studies I could
trace it back all the way to [snorts]
well the beast of revelation and the
Jesuit order and roianism and the
Illuminati and all of these with the the
basic influence of this kind of
philosophy. Pier Tailad desadin who was
associated with the United Nations. He
was basically the spiritual father of
the United Nations and they're all based
on this philosophy of this Blavatsky
thinking where Lucifer is in actually
actually becomes the wronged one and uh
this spirit entity is basically deity
just as we are deity in that way of
thinking.
Yes. So I I was trained by
my father-in-law. Well, not I I wouldn't
call it trained but informed and given
guidelines as to how to become deeper
involved and I could do things like out
of body experiences which they called
oops and that becomes very real.
Actually it's a hypnotic implant. It's
not a reality, but it feels pretty real.
And therefore, you feel this kind of
superiority.
Uh, I could do what they called aura
reading. Uh, look at the colors of an
aura of a person. If the aura was red,
then you knew, well, this one was angry.
And you had to be careful how you
approach this particular person. If you
if you saw that the aura was yellow or
blue, you would interpret it in a
different fashion. So you become
involved in all of those levels and your
life is regulated by this way of
thinking. And there is definitely no
room for a personal god in any of that.
So when you bring the devil into your
life, into your family's life, how how
does that look practically speaking? Um
did this work well for your young family
as you were dabbling with these things
and the father-in-law had had moved
beside you?
>> Exactly. The opposite is true.
Now, let me let me point let me put it
this way. You know, there's a battle
between good and evil. Mhm. And there's
a battle between God and the devil. It's
called the great controversy.
And the devil likes to have you under
his control. But in a sense, he also
hates humanity and wants to make life as
difficult as possible, torture you
mentally and if possible phys
physically, which was the case in our
life.
And God permits it so that eventually
you come to the point where you ask some
very serious questions
and uh that actually happened in our
life. So we were inundated with
spiritual poltergeist phenomena which
were very very serious. They started off
uh in a more abstract way like plates
flying through your house, smashing
against walls, glasses flying off
tables.
I remember being uh in a in a Ouija
board situation
where three of us were sitting at a
Ouija board communicating with the
spirit world. And you know even if you
are steeped in those things there is
still a skeptic inside of every single
one of us. You know is this thing real?
Is this thing somehow part of your
subconscious? Where does it come from?
Is there a real entity to whom you are
talking? You still have those questions
even though you have the experiences.
and we were talking and I said, uh, you
know, I'm going to try and contact my
deceased mother.
Of course, the Bible calls that
necromancy, but I didn't know anything
about the Bible. So, God forgave my
ignorance at that stage. [cough]
Excuse [clears throat] me. And I started
asking questions to [snorts] this spirit
entity. And you keep your finger on that
glass and it moves and spells out from
the alphabet certain things and it moves
pretty sluggishly in the beginning and
you're wondering, you know, is it your
finger that is doing this or is it
somebody else's finger that is on this
glass that is doing this? How does this
happen? But eventually this spirit
entity became very obnoxious
and started moving at breathtaking speed
that nobody could control. So it was not
one of us at least and we could hardly
keep up with the movement of the glass
and it would answer no or yes to certain
questions. But then it started swearing
and spelling out swear words
>> and it would move so violently that it
would literally shoot out from under our
finger and smash against the wall of
glass. So there was definitely some
other force that was involved there. And
in that situation you get the fright of
your life and you let it be for the
while. You're not going to continue with
this thing now. And after that, you
know, I had all of these poltergeist
experiences in the house and some of
them were pretty horrendous.
And eventually you're wondering, how are
you going to solve this?
And the solution then pops up
automatically in your mind. You know,
the church tells you or the Roman
Catholic Church says, "Give me a child
to the eighth year and I'll have him
forever." And there's some measure of
truth in that. And uh you know there
were movies like the exorcist for
example.
So I even though an atheist consulted
the Roman Catholic Church to do an
exorcism in my house which they
proceeded to do and the problem was
gone.
>> Mhm.
>> Now that is that is very convincing.
Now I was happy to have the problem gone
but I wasn't uh willing to reciprocate
by going back to church at that stage.
It took a second round a few years later
where things were really bad when my
youngest son was born
and uh things went terribly wrong in our
home and this child was being accosted
after he was born. even before he was
born. My my wife nearly died uh during
that pregnancy
and there were spiritual phenomena that
you could not explain.
For example, I would be attacked in the
in the middle of the night at precisely
2:00 in the morning. And as soon as I
got out of this terrible uh occult
experience of being strangled in my
sleep, then this child would scream
incredibly
and develop an instant high fever that
was so high that it was
life-threatening.
And if this happens, you know, 20, 30
times in a row, then eventually you
realize that you are dealing with
something that you cannot rationally
explain.
And I actually returned again to the
same source for relief.
And again the same thing happened. The
priest came to my house. He did an
exorcism. He did a mass in my house. Was
a very strange event. He put uh his holy
water against the window panes and
against the mirrors etc. Hung crosses
and amuletes above beds. And the problem
was gone.
And this time round
uh it was so much greater of an issue
than just plates flying around. So it it
sort of developed uh the recip
reciprocity in me and I said to myself,
you know, you're just going to take this
now for the second time and and not uh
you know, go and investigate what this
church is all about. So I ended up
becoming again a Catholic. So I was a
Catholic up to the age of about 10 and
then an atheist
and then uh at the age of 38 I went back
to the Catholic church as a consequence
of this thing and the problem was
basically gone in my house. So obviously
they had solved it in my thinking
>> or was it a deception?
And uh I sat in this church and I went
through the rituals and you know you go
through the mass and you go to
confession and you go through all of
these things and your child my eldest
boy was at the point where you had to
introduce him to the church. So he went
for confirmation classes and he had uh
the catechism in the house again and was
studying. There was no Bible study in
whatsoever. It was all catechism
and went through the process.
And then one day I had an experience at
the university.
There was a young girl that got up in my
science class
and she
she she basically said she doesn't
believe what I'm saying because I was
talking about the evolution of the
kidney. And she said, "God created it."
And that created such a fur in me
because how dare this young whippers
snapper first year medical student
attack the
this evolutionist who had been trained
at university for years sits with PhDs
behind his names and this one comes and
says, "You know, this is all nonsense.
God did it." So I lambasted the poor
girl that she sat down in tears
and my conscience bothered me not for
what I had said but for the way in which
I had said it. And so my solution to the
problem was well maybe I should confess
this thing.
And so in my break at the university, at
the lunch break, I went to the little
local Catholic church to go and talk to
the priest and basically be absolved
from my indiscretion
[laughter]
and he wasn't there. He was out
shopping.
And I sat there and one of the nuns came
to me and said, you know, why don't you
sit in the church until he arrives?
Now in Catholic thinking, if you if you
die in a in a sin like one that would be
considered a mortal sin which leads to
eternal separation, well then you go
directly to hell and you don't pass go
and you don't collect 200 bucks and you
sit there for all eternity. So, it's a
pretty serious thing. If you're not
absolved from your sin
and a bus drives over you before you get
that opportunity, that's it. Your
tickets, you're going to the bad place.
And I sat there in that church
contemplating this. And it didn't make
sense to me. And I I started thinking to
myself, you know, it does God place you
in a position where you are dependent
upon a human being who can or in this
case not be available
and in between the period when he is
available and not available you die.
Then you go straight to hell. That
doesn't seem like a logical system to
me.
And then I thought as I sat there now if
there is a god as these uh religious
systems profess
was hard for me because I'd become an
atheist.
Uh then why would he need this goeteen
to forgive you something? Why would you
be dependent upon him when he's out
shopping?
>> He should be here. He should be there
24/7 in case you have a problem. right
now. The only one who would be there
24/7 is a living deity. And I looked at
the at this little cabinet that they
have with a little red candle in front
of it which says that the consecrated
host is in it which means the body of
Christ is in there.
uh because in Catholic thinking the host
is literally through the process of
transsubstantiation converted into the
literal body of Christ.
Now what use was that to me because he
was a corpse
>> cannot talk.
>> So there was God. He was in that box in
the church where I was sitting and he
was a corpse. So I couldn't talk to him.
Right, Martin?
>> Doesn't help.
>> Doesn't help to talk to him. The priest
wasn't there. He was out shopping, which
was very inconvenient.
And I mowled this over in my mind and
came to the conclusion that I was
probably not being logical and that this
whole thing was being duped.
And I sat up in that church because he
just didn't arrive. And I only have a
limited time because I've got to go back
to teaching.
And now whatever bus runs over me. And I
said I said something which I believe to
this day that God accepted as a prayer.
I got up in a in a bit of an anger
state, frustrated, let's say frustrated
more than angry.
And I said, "God,
if you exist,
then reveal yourself to me." and I left.
And I left with the determination not to
return because the system didn't make
sense to me.
And God actually answered that prayer.
Sometimes I wonder whether it was a good
thing [laughter] or not. But in
retrospect, yes, it was a good thing.
Although it did change my life and
turned it upside down.
>> Well, we got to go right there. This is
the best part of the story. I mean,
you've been afflicted now with
evolution. You've been afflicted with an
abusive religion. You've been
dissatisfied with this Catholicism that
you had somewhat gotten involved with.
You're still an evolutionist at this
point. Had you read the Bible? Did you
have a Bible as a as a Catholic?
>> I never had a Bible. I've never read the
Bible.
And uh I I knew the Catechism book, but
I didn't have a Bible.
But uh through circumstances at that
stage I came into a position where I
inherited a little bit of money from my
deceased father
and uh I decided that our house had
become too small for our family and the
rooms and the kitchen and everything was
pokey and if I removed a few walls then
I could change the situation.
So, I decided to renovate the house,
much to my wife's [laughter]
discouragement, let's put it that way,
because being a very uh impulsive German
[laughter] with a very direct nature,
once I had determined that uh it was
structurally safe to modify the house, I
didn't wait for a consultant or a
builder, but grabbed a 12point hammer
and modified the place myself,
[laughter]
which meant my poor wife didn't have a
kitchen. She had to go and cook outside
in the garage under a primus stove.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it's it's a destruction site.
>> Yes. I destroyed it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And it stays like that for a
while.
>> Yes. There was a [laughter] there was a
little dining cove and there was a
massive wall between that and the
kitchen. So, I removed the entire wall
plus all the cabinets that were attached
to it.
>> Did you at least give your wife time to
just move away some stuff? I thought
>> nothing. The poor woman was running
around [laughter]
with brooms and stuff trying to save
some of her things. But I was very
satisfied with the massive space that I
had created. [laughter]
But now it had to be reconstructed. So I
had to get a builder to plaster some
some of the broken walls and bring them
into a state that uh was satisfactory.
And then I had to get a new kitchen
cabinet or new kitchen cabinets because
the old ones were destroyed.
And uh I looked it up in a in a in a
yellow pages in those days. and I found
a a cabinet maker in a in a little town
close to us and phoned him up and lo and
behold the man was a German.
That uh was even more satisfactory to me
because I knew at least the cabinet
cabinets would be straight and not skew.
[laughter]
So I invited him to come and give me a
quote and he arrived at my house and his
first words were uh before I start I
just want to tell you that I walk with
Jesus.
[laughter]
That totally freaked me out. I had not
come to the stage of of accepting
something like that. So I was pretty
well almost rude to him. I said to him,
"Well, I'm very happy for you that you
walking with Jesus, but as for me, I
just want the kitchen cabinets. So you
you are happily you can go and walk with
your Jesus, but for me, just give me
some kitchen cabinets." So he gave me a
quote
and then he started uh very soon
thereafter installing these kitchen
cabinets. And while he was busy, I was
of course inspecting his handiwork. I
was very impressed with it. And at some
stage, he gave me a pamphlet
and I peered at the pamphlet and saw it
was religious.
So I knew, okay, this is a walking with
Jesus pamphlet.
And I didn't want to be as rude as I was
last time. And so I popped it into a
drawer. Uh, if it'd been gone at that
stage, I would have popped it into the
waste paper basket. But because it was
there, I popped it into a drawer.
And there it lay for a year. Yeah. For a
whole year.
>> And uh
what happened then is the house was
finished.
It looked quite nice.
And uh I thought to myself,
well, this has been quite a successful
little venture.
And I came home one afternoon from the
university for lunch. I wasn't too far
from the university, so I could
sometimes pop home for lunch.
And I was looking for something and I
rummaged through this drawer for
something that I was looking for. I
don't even remember what it was. and I
came across this pamphlet
and for the first time I actually looked
at it and it was a pamphlet that said
that the Catholic Church had changed the
commandments of God
and I I looked at it and it had three
sets of commandments on it. The first
set of commandments was as they appear
in the Catholic Catechism.
The second set, the central set was as
they appear in the scriptures in the
Bible. And the third set was as they
appear in the Lutheran
um catechism.
So there were three sets of commandments
on there and it said that the
commandments had been changed.
Now this puzzled me and I thought to
myself, I don't understand what that
means. What I don't what does this even
mean?
So I said to my wife, uh, excuse me, do
we have a Bible in the house?
And she said, "No, we don't have a Bible
in the house. Uh, do we have catechism
in the house?" "Yes, we have a
catechism." Because my son, remember,
went to catechism classes. So I went to
his room and rummaged through his things
and sure enough I found the catechism.
Looked up the ten commandments and the
catechism and they were exactly like it
was on the pamphlet, the Catholic
>> version [clears throat] of the ten
commandments.
Now I needed a Bible to compare it. I
didn't have one.
So I remembered an old lady that had
left me. Uh she was a lady was a
paraplegic and she had left me her
entire life's possessions in her in in
her testament when she passed away and
that consisted of one box of old
magazine and books. She she had no
possessions, but she was a a dear old
lady and we had sort of uh you know
taken care of her on occasions.
And then I thought she must have a
Bible. She was a Lutheran. So I went and
found this box that I'd stored in the
garage
and I found an old tattered German
Bible.
Now, it was quite a job finding
Deuteronomy and
>> where the commandments are written
because you
>> I don't even know where they're written.
[laughter]
And then, of course, it it talked about
Exodus. And um in in the German Bible,
it's not called Genesis, Exodus. It's
called Asta Mozam.
The first book of Moses, the second book
of Mo. I didn't find an Exodus. There
was no Exodus in the
>> And you didn't have Google.
>> I didn't have Google. There was no
Google. So eventually I discovered it
was initi
which is Exodus
and lo and behold the ten commandments
were as they were on the pamphlet. I
didn't have the Protestant version so I
didn't have that but this was enough.
And it tickled my curiosity. So I phoned
this guy after one year
and I said to him, "What's going on
here? you left me a pamphlet a year ago.
Oh yeah, I remember you, he said. So I
said, I'd like to know what's happening
on this pamphlet. Have you got any
explanation? He said, can I come and
visit you? And I said, sure.
And he came to my house and we sat right
through the night.
Right through the night. And we went
through the book of Daniel
>> right through including Daniel chapter 7
which basically knocked the socks off me
and uh that explained that this little
horn power had changed times and laws
and there was the evidence they had
changed it and their own statements some
of them were also on the pamphlet agreed
with this sentiment. Now, I didn't know
whether this this was historic truth or
whether this was conjecture or whether
this was mythology or whatever. So, I I
said to this carpenter, "Okay, let me
think about this stuff." And so he left
and I went to the university library
and I I actually played squash with uh
one of my colleagues at the university
who happened to be in the theology
department. Uh we never spoke religion.
We only played squash together
and I I asked him and he said no he he
doesn't have the foggiest idea about any
of these things but I'm welcome to use
the theology library which I did. So I I
spent some time in my free periods
ramaging through the theology library
looking up the history of the church and
all of this stuff. And lo and behold,
no matter how much I tried to negate it
and how many times I tried to, you know,
get rid of this this new uh irritant in
my life,
I just couldn't do it. I found more and
more evidence that this was actually
true. I tried to speak to my theologian
friend. He was not not too impressed.
And so eventually I I called the
Catholic church and I called this
priest, the one who was shopping. He was
still there. And uh I said to him, could
you please uh explain this to me? So he
came to my house and I said to him,
okay, here's the ten commandments. Here
they are in the catechism. Here they are
in the Bible. And then this is how it
was changed. And then there are these
verses in Daniel which says that this
power would change times and laws and do
this that that and the other. All the 13
points in there.
And he looked with at me with a blank
stare that I I probably will never
forget.
And he said to me, "I'm not into
scripture."
>> Now that knocked my socks off. Yeah.
>> So I said to him, "But you're a priest.
>> How can you not know the scriptures? I
can understand me. I'm a lay person. I
don't know the scriptures. But you,
you're a priest. How can you not know
the scriptures?" And he said, "No, we
have specialists that deal with the
scriptures. I could send you one of
them, but it'll take some time to get
hold of one of them." So I said,
"Specialists within the church that deal
with the scriptures?" All right. So he
left leaving me with a big hole in my
mind
and I thought now that's not right. I
must get somebody who deals with
scriptures. So that must be a
Protestant, right? Mhm.
>> So I again consulted the yellow pages
and found the Methodist pastor in the
town and asked him to come and enlighten
me on some points in scripture. And he
also came to my house and this guy he
brought a young intern with him and uh
they were doing a visit two by two. And
down we sat and I asked him about the
ten commandments
and the change of the ten commandments.
Well, he knew nothing about that. So I
asked him, "What is your view on the
antichrist?"
And he told me the antichrist was
Antiochus Epipanis IVth,
a Greek king who had desecrated the
temple for approximately three and a
half years. But I was prepared for that
one. So I did a Bible study with him on
Daniel chapter 7 and showed him that it
couldn't be a Greek king because this
power that changed the times and the
laws came out of the fourth empire which
was Roman.
And the more I did the Bible study, the
more agitated he became
because he would say, "No, it's a Greek
king." I said, "It can't be. He comes
out of the fourth kingdom." Yeah, it's
very clear. And this young intern, his
head was spinning. He was looking at his
pastor and he was looking at me and he
was looking at his pastor and he was
looking at me. And eventually this
pastor jumped up from his chair,
literally
grabbed this young guy by the head,
stopped his ears, closed his ears with
his hands, and marched him out of my
house.
>> [laughter]
>> Now that left another big hole in my
head because what now? So the Protestant
world
totally
was incapable of explaining these
things. The Catholic world was totally
incapable of explaining these things. So
what now?
So I invited this carpenter back
>> and we spent a couple of days going
through Daniel and Revelation
and then eventually we got to the
question of the fourth commandment.
And there was a major problem for me
because in six days the Lord made the
heavens, the earth, the sea, and all
that is in them. And he rested on the
seventh day. And therefore he commanded
you to keep holy the seventh day of the
week. And I said to this this carpenter,
but this is this is insane
because nobody created this world in six
days. It's millions and millions of
years old.
And this process of evolution took
millions of years. There's no such thing
as a six day creation.
So he started arguing with me. But he
was a carpenter and I was a professor.
How could he argue with me? This was
ridiculous. It was like David and
Goliath in my in my my thinking in terms
of this issue. Eventually, he got fed up
with me [laughter] because he couldn't
answer my questions.
And so, he arrived one day with a huge
pile on of creation books. and he put
them on my lap
and I took them with me to the
university and I and I went through
them. Every single one of them I studied
them. I'm an avid reader and I came to
the conclusion that I've never written
read so much rubbish in all my life. And
so I informed them that the books were a
lot of rubbish. Well, his answer to that
was to bring me another pile of books.
[laughter] Having gone through those, I
again concluded that they were a lot of
rubbish because they just didn't conform
to my my way of thinking. And so he got
annoyed with me and he said, "You know
what? I don't have a problem with
evolution. You have a problem with
evolution. So why should I solve it? You
solve it." And he left.
Now, that took the wind right out of my
sails. I didn't know how to answer that
one. So off I went and I went to my my
office and I took out all the evolution
books that I had on my on my shelf
and I started comparing whatever was
going on there. And then uh I came to an
impass where I couldn't go any further
and I thought, you know, I'm going to go
to our library and see if there's
anything new out there that can throw
some light on this issue. So I went to
our our university uh zoology library,
which is a very welltoed evolutionary
stronghold.
and I found a book on paleontology that
uh tickled my interest and I took it off
the shelf,
signed it out and went down the passage
to my office when a colleague of mine
stopped me. This is amazing
because he was walking in the passage
and he saw me with this book in my hand
and he said to me, you know, there's a
new edition of that book.
I I don't know how he actually even saw
what was in my hand because on which
edition
>> what was how did he know what was in my
hand, right? And he said there's a new
edition of that book in in and it's
still packed in the box at the back. How
would he know that? Right. He's not the
librarian. He's one of my colleagues.
So I said, "Okay, where?" He said, "No,
they're stacked in the back there." So I
went to the back back to the library,
found the box of books that he was
talking to, opened it up, and lo and
behold, here was a new edition of the
same book.
So I thought, now what I'm going to do,
put the old one back and sign the new
one out or so I signed them both out and
I took them to my study. So now I had
two editions of the same book, one an
old edition and one a new edition.
And for some strange reason, I read them
in parallel. You know, like windows, you
open two documents and I put them side
by side. So I went page by page opening
them up and reading the same page in
both in both of them. And what stunned
me was that the old one was honest
>> and the new one wasn't. It was it was
couched in scientific terminology to
cover up certain issues and the issue
was the issue of intermediary fossils.
Now the old one was absolutely clear
that there are no intermediary fossils
and all of those that are there are
infernals. They are mind constructs.
they're not really uh real.
Whereas the new one would gloss that
over and give them all scientific names.
>> And so I realized, but there's something
deceptive here. I I didn't understand
what it was,
but I realized there was something
deceptive.
And I inadvertently
said [snorts] a prayer without knowing
that I was saying a prayer. I said, "My
God,
if there's something wrong here, then
maybe there's something more wrong. And
if there is a God, then he could perhaps
show me
>> what is wrong." Again, one of those
dangerous prayers.
And as I was mulling it over then in my
mind,
I eventually forgot about it because I
have other things to do. You can't
concentrate on this. You have classes to
give. You have students to take care of.
You have thesis to read. You have so
many things to do. You you can't mull on
one thing all the time.
And I was also preparing to give a
course to the medical students on
genetics
and uh developmental genetics in
particular.
And so I was preparing this course on on
genetics.
And as I was preparing this course in
genetics,
certain ideas popped into my mind which
which absolutely flabbergasted me
because you know there's an idea in in
evolutionary thinking that natural
selection doesn't operate on the level
of the genotype. It only operates on the
level of the phenotype.
Which means it cannot it cannot
influence the words. Let me put it
simply. It cannot influence the words in
this book. It can only influence the
result of the words which is the animal
itself. So natural selection doesn't
read the genes. It looks at the result
of the genes. This creature has long
legs. This one has short legs. This one
runs fast. This one runs slow. Which one
has a selective advantage? But it cannot
influence the actual gene system. So the
question arises, well then who wrote the
book?
>> The genes are basically the blueprint,
the book of who and what you are and how
you constructed. So who wrote the book?
Well, in evolution, chance wrote the
book.
And that's why Dawkins has a book which
he wrote which is a prescribed book in
most universities in in phoggenetic
studies and it's called the blind
watchmaker.
So how did a tinkerer get to construct
the watch?
>> Because he doesn't have a blueprint,
right?
>> Where does he get that?
>> He wrote that book.
>> But where does he what does he conclude?
>> He concluded that the the watch maker
was blind. He was just putting things
together and by chance eventually if you
give enough time something came
together.
>> But I was dealing with the most
intricate, most involved, most precise
genetic u phenomena that have to be
absolutely precise like clockwork
because you cannot afford a mistake
because you turn into a cabbage instead
of a human being. If there are mistakes
in your genetic system, I mean just one
little chromosomeal non-isjunction or or
whatever and there's a massive disaster
in the offspring, right?
So the questions started arising how did
these things come about
and I developed uh some basic questions
there were about 10 of them
[clears throat] and I put them on paper
not having the answers
and at a university level you have a
discussion class with colleagues and
post-graduate students on how you know
the evolutionary processes work whether
they're fast or whether they're slow.
Fast one is called Tackitely. Slow ones
are called Brady Teley and all kinds of
philosophical ideas. And I decided to
write my 10 questions on the board
and I never expected the result. All I
did was write 10 questions on the board
and it created
pandemonium.
pandemonium. They were furious with me
because the questions were unanswerable
and they they turned the philosophy of
evolution on its head. So I have a
lecture now which is called the 10
questions.
>> 10 points to ponder. 10 points to ponder
which is basically based on on what
happened there of course with some
solutions now which I didn't have then
but just the questions alone totally
upset my career to the point where I
couldn't operate at that level anymore
and resign from the university.
>> Yeah,
>> Martin, please give me that link to the
10 questions to ponder. I want to post
that also in the description. Um, you're
walking step by step into the truth now.
And by the way, the what's up prophet
>> with the end table with the Bibles on it
right there.
>> Yes.
>> That is so fitting to typify your
testimony, your ministry of decades that
the Bible is central. The Bible is a
foundation. The Bible is is before the
man. I see I see an artistic view of
this of this Bible- centered life that's
developing now in the story and as
you're walking into the truth are are
you relieved still of the demonic
manifestations? Has the has the Catholic
exorcism held? What's the turn in the
story there? And then I want to go back
to your university as well to
everybody's furious. You left us on a
cliffhanger there. But but start with
the the spiritual walk here and the
protection against the enemy.
>> Very good point. I'm glad you brought me
back because my mind will wander in a
totally different direction. Uh the the
Catholic exorcism held up until that
point.
As soon as I started consulting this
book
and realizing that the very first words
in this book which read in the beginning
in the beginning God
>> and then starts with the creation
account of six days
that perhaps that was not a mythology
but a fact that is a major mindset
change so it doesn't happen it doesn't
happen with a lightning bolt because
there's so much to rationalize and think
through and rethink and uh reorganize
and whatever.
So it was a it was a slow painful
process. But as I became involved in the
study of the scripture,
the manifestations
started up with a [snorts]
with a fervor that you will not imagine.
And the same sort of catastrophic events
took place in my house. There was
absolute pandemonium. The strangulations
at night, the screaming, the sickness,
all of it returned with a vengeance.
And now where was I going to turn to?
And the interesting thing is
I I was mulling this all over, having
now studied by at this stage already the
state of the dead, for example,
uh knowing that the dead know nothing,
that the dead sleep. This ties in with
what we said in the beginning with the
doctrine of hell because my father was
obviously dead. My mother was dead. So
it was very comforting to me to find out
that they shouldn't be aware of the mess
that I had been in and that they were
blissfully sleeping awaiting the
resurrection.
And I was now on a path where the Bible
was becoming my norm rather than a
church whether Protestant or Catholic
because both had been in my house and
hadn't supplied any answers.
>> So the only place where I could look for
the answers was in the Bible.
And so when when my my quest for truth
started harmonizing with what the
scriptures were saying, I became very
involved in in the alternative way of
thinking when it comes to creation and
that uh what we see in the
paleontological record is a record of
catastrophism
uh based on flood geology, the universal
flood as described in the Bible.
and that it far better explains the
phenomena that we have than science.
Then all of these things started
happening and manifesting in my home
>> and the only recourse I had was prayer
and this carpenter
uh who had been very instrumental. He
introduced me to some people from the
church and they started praying for me
and while they were praying things
calmed down in my house and then
fascinatingly
I got a phone call. Now remember this is
more than a year
later
more than a year must be more
>> after the exorcism. After the exorcism,
it must be a year and 6 months or
something like this.
>> Suddenly this exorcist pastor who had
come to my house or priest that had come
to my house and done the exorcism
out of the blue phones me
and I remember picking up the phone and
speaking to him
and he says to me, "You are on a wrong
path." M. And I said, "What do you mean
I'm on a wrong path?"
He says, "You are dabbling. You must you
are dabbling in things you shouldn't be
dabbling in. You better get back to
church."
And I said, "How do you know that I'm
not at church?"
He was from a totally different town, by
the way.
And he said to me,
"The nuns told me."
And I said, "Excuse my ignorance, but
how did the nuns know who are in a
monastery in another town
and uh those nuns that don't mingle with
the world but stay in the nannery?"
They had told him that I was doing these
things. So I said, "How do these nuns
know?"
And he said, "My father had told them."
And something went click in my mind. And
I said to him, "Uh, excuse me. How do
they know what my father said?" And they
said, "Well, you they're in
communication with my father and your
father happens to be in purgatory and
he's suffering there on your behalf."
And then of course I had studied the
doctrine of hell and I'd studied the
doctrine of purgatory at that stage and
I'd studied the state of the dead. None
of that was in any way in harmony with
what is written in this book. And
therefore I put two and two together.
These nuns were practicing seances
>> and they were talking to the spirit
world which because they are not the
deceased are actually demons parading as
the deceased. They had told her these
things just as previously before he came
to my house the first time. He was
telling me what was going on in my house
without me having told him what was
going on in my house. And that so
impressed me that I actually went back
to Catholicism. But this was this was
spiritism. They were talking to demons.
And I could not be fooled anymore
because I had read the truth. And to
some extent I had internalized it enough
to know that their system was based on a
lie. Now they themselves they don't even
know that they're in a lie. Martin, this
is the sad thing.
>> They don't know it.
that you just gave a very important
um suggestion or possibility for people
because we I don't know about you Scott
but we've got many people that ask how
do I deal with the demonic um
infestation and everything.
>> Yes. And you mentioned prayer is one of
the power most powerful tools.
>> And so so Scott when I realized
how deep the rabbit hole goes
and how at the basis of all of it is the
lie of Eden.
Thou shalt surely not die. They you will
be like gods and you will set up your
own standards of what is right and
wrong. you will distinguish between good
and evil. You don't need God or his law
in order for you to do that. And the
whole concept of law
explains the plan of salvation
because it is because of the
transgression of the law and the penalty
which is death that Christ came to pay
that penalty on my behalf.
So the whole plan of salvation and the
atonement is involved in this. And the
Catholic Church denies the atonement.
The Catholic Church says Christ never
paid the price for your sins. You still
have to pay the price and that's why you
have to go to purgatory.
Purgatory is the proof that they do not
believe in the atonement.
They believe in his sacrifice. Yes. They
believed that it was an act of obedience
to the point of death. But it was not on
behalf of your sins.
It was to bring satisfaction for your
sins. But you have to pay for your own
sins.
And you are immortal. You cannot die.
Therefore, you are a god. Therefore, the
son of man,
the the son of God became man so that we
may become God. that statement verbatim
is in that catechism.
So the whole the whole plethora of a
false concept about God just exploded in
my mind. And then I had this experience
of the Protestant pastor who had
forgotten all about the teachings of the
Reformation and the Antichrist and had
swallowed a Catholic doctrine hook,
line, and sinker.
And I talk about Protestantism, whether
they actually did a better job on the
character of God than the Catholics did.
And the fact of the matter is no they
didn't [clears throat] because they
invented some other doctrines like
predestination
which is basically the doctrine of the
Sadducees that you are a chosen nation
on the basis of your your genealogy.
And therefore, God has certain people
that are predestined to go to heaven and
others that are predestined to go to
hell for all eternity without giving you
any choice in the matter because you are
suffering from total depravity.
That's Calvinism. And I thought to
myself, you know, Wesley was right.
Wesley says this makes a monster out of
God because it's not much better than
the doctrine of of
eternal punishment of the Roman Catholic
system. It's exactly the same. In fact,
it's worse because God doesn't even give
you a chance to make a decision. So,
I found it interesting that those
gentlemen in the video that you
mentioned right there in the beginning,
Scott,
that they said that they're dealing here
with the character of God.
And they actually asked the question
whether the church had done a good job
in portraying that character.
And I come to the conclusion, Scott,
that the church has done a terrible job
in selling the character of God. Yes,
they talk about the love of Jesus, but
they add eternal damnation to it and
they add predestination to it in a very
large sector of that thinking which
makes God the arbitrary monster who
decides that who will suffer for all
eternity, choice or no choice. It's a
terrible, terrible doctrine.
>> It sure is. And how can how can you
exercise faith and trust in that picture
of God? If we're saved by faith, that's
a pretty important link for my salvation
to know God's love and see him as
trustworthy. And then I place my faith
in him. Yes. And choose thee this day
whom you will serve. And then if the
righteous man turns from his
righteousness and does what is evil in
the sight of the Lord, none of his
former righteousness will be remembered.
And if the wicked man turns from his
wickedness
and does that which is right in the
sight of the Lord, none of his former
wickedness will be remembered. He will
certainly live. Talking about eternal
life. Why will you die, oh house of
Israel? Turn, turn from your evil ways
and live. I have no pleasure in the
death of the wicked. What a beautiful
symbol of God lies shattered on the road
of theology.
And the character of God is trampled
upon more by the church than by anyone
else. I believe there are more atheists
in the world because of doctrine
than there are for any other reason.
>> That's sad but true.
So you're coming to a knowledge of the
truth at this stage. That's not the
worldview of the university in which you
are uh not yet a professor, but you're
being invited to be, I believe, the
youngest professor on staff. You're in
charge of all of the graduate students.
You're a rising star in the art sciences
of physical sciences at was it the
university with the largest evolution
library in the country. This is a big
deal for a person to be coming to these.
Tell us what happens next. Are you going
to break this to your co colleagues?
Yeah, I was I was not a professor at
that stage. I was a senior lecturer.
So I resigned from the university. I
actually had a talk to the recctor and
he asked me why I was resigning
and he was a replacement recctor at that
stage and I said to him, I cannot I
cannot reconcile teaching the theory of
evolution with my conscience any longer.
And he he basically asked me to
compromise on the issue, you know, to
teach it but not necessarily believe it.
And I said to him, I can't do that. I
can't do that. And so he he wished me
well for my future life. And I thought
my career was tanked. I was well, let's
let's put it this way in terms of
academia. was a little rising star, a
young academic,
uh, senior lecturer at that age already.
And professorships are very scarce.
There's only one or two in a in a
department. So, you have to wait until
someone dies before you get one of
those. And so, I thought my university
career was over.
And so I went into a short period, a
nine-month stint of farming.
Uh I thought, you know, as a
zoologologist, I was pretty uh
comfortable with working with livestock.
And so of all things, Scott, I went into
dairy farming
with a couple of partners.
And I learned very quickly that there is
no ship that sinks like a partnership.
>> [laughter]
>> Let's leave some of that history out of
it. But within nine months, we were
basically bankrupt. And one of the
reasons for the bankruptcy had nothing
to do with my partners. It had to do
with government policy
because our government was the pariah of
the world because of the apartheite
policy in this country. And so we were
placed as a nation under international
sanctions
which meant that the value of our money
crashed and interest rates soared.
And so what started off as a 5% loan on
a business ended up as a 36% loan which
no income
uh would be able to generate from any
farm. And so many many farmers and
industries went totally bankrupt
uh including myself.
And as I was wondering how am I going to
feed my family in this calamity?
Everything went wrong in our lives. We
knelt down one day my wife and I having
found the faith and then also having
discovered
that uh we were doing things wrong. We
were eating wrong. We were drinking
wrong and we'd read some some marvelous
books. The most uh uh surprising one,
let's put it that way, that really
turned my life upside down was a book
that my wife read and it was called
Councils on Diets and Food. I don't know
whether I should rejoice or regret the
day that she read it, but it certainly
changed our life.
And uh I read a book called The Desire
of Ages at the same time. And here we
were destitute
with a a new outlook on what is right
and what is wrong and what your body
needs and what it doesn't need and no
job and no money. And so we prayed to
God and actually put our our thoughts on
a on a piece of paper and said to God,
you know, there are these promises in
your word and right now we could we
could use some fulfilled promises and
you have promised that you will take
care of all our needs and our needs are
pretty desperate.
And that very day after that prayer, no
the next morning, sorry. We said that
prayer in the evening, put the letter
down on the floor, we kn on the floor.
And the next morning early, I get a
phone call from another university.
And the professor there says that one of
his colleagues has taken ill and he
needs a a rapid replacement. and he
can't think of anyone at the moment who
can teach the courses that this
particular person taught because they
were physiological in nature. Would I be
prepared to jump in
at this late hour and take over those
classes?
So I said to him, you've probably heard
about my life change. And he said, yes,
I know about it. And I said, "And you
probably know that uh I've become
sort of the outcast of the scientific
fraternity, not believing in evolution
anymore." He says, "Yes, I know, but I I
need a physiologist and you're a
physiologist. Could you do it?" And
secretly I rejoiced and I said, "Okay."
And he said, "All right, let me do the
paperwork. I'll call you back later in
the day."
and he called me back later in the day
and he said to me, "Uh,
well,
you start on Monday."
I said, "What? You start on Monday?"
This was Friday.
[laughter]
This created an even bigger pregnant
problem because I had a dairy farm and
cows don't wait to be to be milked,
right? Who's going to take care of them?
And so we had another problem. So I
said, "Okay, I'll get back to you. Thank
you very much." And then we wrestled
with God and said, "Now we've got a big
problem because Monday is a weekend away
and I have to be at the university."
And uh thank God for that income, but
who's going to take care of the farm?
Our words weren't cold when there was a
knock on the door. And we opened the
door and here stood a young couple.
I didn't know this young couple
and uh they said they're here from
another country. They came from Zimbabwe
and Zimbabwe was also going through
turmoil at that stage and they were
Sabbathke keepers and they had worked at
a farm at a dairy farm but uh you know
you can milk cows on on a dairy farm but
you don't do the other chores on a on a
Sabbath. And so they had been kicked off
the farm because they were Sabbathke
keepers. And they said that they needed
a place to stay
uh and they would work for free if they
could get a place to stay.
So I asked them, would you be prepared
to run this little dairy farm of ours?
And there's a there's a little income
from the dairy farm. It doesn't cover
the costs of the dairy farm and it
doesn't cost cover the costs for the
bank. But if you could take that income,
you could live reasonably from that
income and then if I get a job at the
university, I can pay the other debts
with my salary then that I will be
receiving. Would you be able to take?
They were overjoyed. They jumped out of
their skin. So within one day, God gave
me a job at the university and he gave
me someone to take care of the farm.
Now Scott, it's amazing because uh I I
didn't have a permanent job at the
university. I was just a replacement.
So I received a lecturer's salary in
that time period and it was a year. I
worked there for a year and then the
other person that I had replaced
returned and I asked God, "Now what
happens now?" And then I got another
phone call immediately when I needed it
from the other university which was the
University of Cape Town which is the you
know the prestigious university in the
country where I did my PhD as well and
they of course knew me well because I
did my PhD under them and they had a
similar problem except that the person I
was to replace wasn't sick but went on
sbatical for a year so they asked me to
teach as a senior lecturer.
in a replacement capacity. You know,
nobody wants you when you've when you've
become weird, you're now no longer an
evolutionist. So in any case I hopped
from the one university to the other and
I taught there for a year and when that
tenure came to an end then I got another
call from the first university and they
said you know we have a vacancy
and I think you should apply because
when you were teaching here for a year
it was great because you did
post-graduate work you did stuff that
you know the normal replacement wouldn't
do. would would you consider taking this
job but it's only electorship?
So I said okay uh you know beggars can't
be choosers fine if you want to give it
to me that's great thank you. He said no
job's yours.
So I said great thank you Lord.
And then uh he came back to me a day or
so later and he said you know
something's happened. You could you
can't have the job anymore.
And I said, "Okay, what happened?"
Now, in South Africa, they brought in
new laws which were dealing with uh with
the race issue. And the law was that if
there was a replacement that was not
European like me, then that should
receive precedent.
So that law prohibited them from giving
me the job. So they had to give it to a
person of color.
So I said, "Okay, fine." And so I didn't
get the job. And I said to the Lord,
"Now, what now, Lord? What happens now?"
And a day later, he phoned me back and
he said, "You have the job." And I said,
"What do you mean I have the job?" He
said, "No, the guy that they gave the
job to refused the job because the
salary was too low.
and you were the the sukundus. You were
the second on the list. So under those
circumstances, it was legal to give you
the job because you were placed on the
document as a sukundus, as the second in
in row. So I said, well, that's amazing.
I didn't mind the lower salary. I was
just happy that I could stay alive. And
so I took the the job and I now had a
permanent position at the university.
And I I went to the university, spoke to
the the professor and I started my job.
And this was amazing. You know, God is
so meticulous in what he does.
And they were fully aware of what my
stand is. I wasn't going to teach
evolution. I wasn't going to be involved
in that. And they must leave me alone
with my philosophy. I'm not going to
change. I am a creationist. and I'm not
going to work on Saturdays. [laughter]
And uh they said fine, fine, fine. No
problem. They were in a bind and I was
in a bind. So we had a mutual
arrangement.
And you know, Scott, the interesting
thing is
I didn't have much information on uh
some of the paleontological questions
that I had in my mind on evolution and
the geocscience institute that had some
very fine scientists in those days in
the United States that were
very very meticulous uh scientists with
wellpublished and They were creationists
and I'm thinking of people like Harold
Coffan and Ariel Roth. They're no longer
with us, but they were absolute
stalwarts. They invited me to come to
the United States for six weeks to go
with them on field trips to see how they
interpret the paleontological record,
which was such an amazing opportunity.
And I had to turn it down because I just
got this job.
So I was sitting there in the job and I
thought wow if I could do that course
six weeks it would be wonderful but
there's there's no chance of me doing
that. But we had so much political
turmoil in the country that riots broke
out over the country. And of course,
riots always spread to universities.
And so there was a lot of stone throwing
and burning down buildings and trashing
cars and smashing equipment happening at
the university. Just as I walked in to
those walls to start my new job
and [clears throat]
the university was in such turmoil that
they shut the university down.
So I went to the professor and I said to
him, I what what happens now? I mean,
I've just started and now the university
is closed. How long is it going to be
closed? He said, six weeks.
I said, well, what must I do now in the
six weeks? Must I must I come to
university and and work here? I mean,
there's riots all around and riot police
everywhere and this and that and the
other. What happens now? He says, you go
home and I don't see you for six weeks.
I said, do I have to stay close by? Do
you need me at any stage? He says, I
don't care if you go to the moon.
[snorts] Don't come back before 6 weeks,
but you'll get your salary.
Isn't that amazing?
>> Oh, sure is. That's incredible. I mean,
just the fact that to begin with, you
are an avowed stubborn creationist and
you're in these senior lecturer
positions. Weren't you the head of a
zoolology department during this phase?
>> No. No. There I was just in an ordinary
lecturer position. I had come from
senior
>> I went right down to a lecturer position
and then for six weeks I went to the
geoscience institute and went on field
trips with Ariel Roth and Harold Coffin
and it so broadened my thinking and
understanding that I worked out an
entire evolution series and I didn't
present it at our university but the
students got interested and asked for
after hours discussions
And so I did that which caused a lot of
constonation. So they knew exactly where
I was standing.
But as a lecturer I was used to working
with post-graduate students.
So immediately
a lot of the students radiated to what I
was teaching and so I had a whole host
of post-graduate students and started a
research program at the university which
exploded. So I had I had about what 25
postgrad students working under me at at
that stage and I was just a lecturer
again. And then the professor got sick
and the professor got cancer
and he said he's only got a few months
to live but he only he only lived six
weeks and he was dead.
So there was a professorship vacant
and so the dean of the of the university
approached me and he said you know I've
been been watching you and you have this
massive research project going and
you've only been here for for less than
a year I want you to apply for this job.
And I said to him well are you sure that
I should apply for this job? He said
sure you have to apply for this job. And
so I I put in an application and I
thought that you know there was no
possibility of of getting that post or
whatever.
And the university went through a what
they call a search committee to find a
suitable candidate for for this
position. And they they advertise
worldwide.
And they had a couple of candidates that
applied and one of them was from a very
very very prominent university in
England. In fact, one of the big two uh
I won't say which one. And then there
were two candidates
that uh were in the running for this
position. And in view of my publication
record and my postgrad research program
that I had started uh this person and I
from this prominent UK university were
running neck andneck
and then they couldn't decide who they
were going to employ and they said you
know but this this guy he started this
research program from with next to
nothing and we need this kind of of
drive in our university. We should take
him.
And the others said, "No, but this
prestigious university will give us a
better name. We should take that
person." And and besides, this fellow is
controversial. He doesn't believe in
evolution and he's controversial. We
can't afford that.
And then someone else got up apparently
and said, "You know what? We are in a
state of political turmoil
and uh we are known for our opposition
and our our standpoint which is contrary
to public opinion sometimes and
controversial is exactly what we need.
So many of them voted for me and some
voted for the other one. And so
eventually they couldn't decide. So they
appointed us both [snorts]
and decided to split the professorship
in two and appoint two of them.
Well, long story short, eventually the
other one didn't pitch up. So I became
the sole professor. So within one year
of being downgraded to a lecturer, I
jumped all the positions and became the
head of the department. And I served
there for 15 years as probably the only
professor in a secular university that
was not an evolutionist.
>> That's incredible.
>> Only by the miraculous hand of God. And
you know there were some other miracles.
Would you mind sharing also in those
early days as the economic turmoil is
happening you had resigned. You hadn't
hadn't yet landed the new lecture
position. How was the Lord providing for
your family during that difficult phase?
>> Basically, my whole salary went into
debt
from this farm venture. I had uh my
partnerships
that sank like a partnership.
They had a way out, but I didn't have a
way out because I inherited some of the
loans and so I paid other people's loans
as well. It was a tough time, but I paid
for 15 years on on those loans until I
eventually delved them and got rid of
them. Then God brought me out of that.
But I had some other interesting
experiences because when you in a
position like that, Scott, and you're
working at a at a secular university
and we had links because I became a
Royal Society grant holder. So we had
links with with universities in the UK.
We had links with universities like
Harvard in the United States. One of my
students became a postdocck at Harvard.
Uh one of my my doctoral students and uh
once you get into that field and you are
you are running at that level but you're
not on the same philosophical level as
the others, you have enemies.
and they cannot understand how someone
who doesn't have the right philosophy in
their opinion can be in that position.
How can you run a department and not
believe in evolution when you're in a
zoology department?
Now, I never opposed the curriculum of
the university. In fact, I said we must
get the very best of all of the the
teachers including evolution. I won't
teach it but you can choose the very
best but I won't teach it because I
don't believe it but of course then you
have enemies because you have two
philosophies running in the same
department
and there were occasions when some of
the insiders would be very malicious and
try to undermine your position with the
university authorities and try to work
you out of your position. uh the
politics at that level can be can be
very harsh indeed and you have to you
have to sort of deal with that and the
only way to deal with it is to be
constantly on your knees. And so at one
stage uh one person had agitated to this
extent where they were going to have a
commission of inquiry as to whether
someone with might philosophy should
have the competence to to be the head of
such a department. And so they they
appointed a commission to investigate
this issue.
And the main accuser
was a a very
uh determined young man and he was
highly educated and he was in in very
good academic standing and he he was of
course in my department and I was his
boss as it were but he didn't take that
lightly and so he he set up this this
document with complaints against
whatever we stood for and this
commission flew in from all over the
country and was going to investigate my
case. And I sat in my office and I and I
said to God, you know, I I don't even
know what all the accusations are that
they're trying to run by me here and
trying to remove me from my position.
But whatever it is, I didn't initiate
this war. So God, please take care of
it.
And I was sitting in my office and his
office was right next to mine
and the commission sat in in the seminar
room and they called him to come and
give his witness.
And he came out of his office with his
document in his hand
that I knew nothing about. For some
strange reason, I never got insight into
what the accusations were at that stage.
And as he walked past my office,
he stood bolt upright.
He's a young man, a fit man, stood bolt
upright and fell over.
And he fell into my secretary's office.
He missed a desk by millimeters with his
head, crashed to the floor and there he
was unconscious.
So there was used constonation. They
called the medics. The medics came
rushing in. They took him out on a on a
stretcher. They put him into an
ambulance and rushed him off to
hospital.
So the witness was gone. So they called
me in [laughter]
because he dropped the document with all
the accusations
and they had the document. I didn't have
the document and they started going
through them one by one. And as they
went through and he had witnesses
but obviously these witnesses were a
setup and so as they went through I said
no it wasn't like this it was like that.
And they said, "No, here he says he has
two witnesses that will testify to that
thing." I said, "No, no, no. This thing
happened in a class."
So there weren't only two witnesses.
There was a whole class that was
witnessing of which these two were
happened to be his students. So that's
their rendition of the story. You have
to listen to the whole story because it
wasn't like that. It was exactly the
opposite. And they said, "Okay, well,
where's this class?" So I said, "I don't
know. I don't know where they are at the
moment. Let me find out. So I I looked
at the roster and I saw that they were
in another department and that those
students were also taking that course.
So they must be at that particular
venue. So I called the professor there
and I said, "Uh, you guys have a class
at the moment and are they with you at
the moment, all of these students?" And
they said, "Yes."
And I said, "Well, here's a commission
that would like to consult with them.
could you, you know, cut your class and
send these over to come and witness? And
they said, "Okay." And so the students
came over and they witnessed us to the
exact opposite. And so they went through
the list and everything was the exact
opposite.
Whereas if he'd been there, he would
have gotten his witnesses to testify as
to his version of the story, whereas I
had the whole class. So eventually he
said, "No, these are all trumped up
starts charges. They're all nonsense.
They tore up the document. They closed
the commission and that was that. So the
next day, Scott, he was back.
I don't know what he had. Nobody knew
what he had. They checked him out at the
hospital from top to bottom. He was
unconscious when he got there. There was
nothing wrong with him. So they sent him
home. The next day he was at work and he
discovered that his whole plot had
disintegrated.
Well, that was fascinating to me how how
something can happen at that split
second.
And I thought to myself, "Wow, this is
absolutely amazing."
And as the circumstances then went, not
very long thereafter, the university did
some restructuring
and some people lost their jobs.
And uh it was not because of competence
that uh this decision was made but on a
basis of first in last out or last in
first out or something like last in
first out. So uh
so overnight
he was gone and that gave me a measure
of peace for a number of years and uh
people left me alone and I could do my
research and I did you know the health
research and started going into diseases
like osteoporosis and and what the
causes were and they were all diet
related and this was fascinating
research.
And that's how it happened. And that was
my university career.
>> Well, I know so many of those listening
to this testimony have enjoyed your
health lectures, your creation science
series, history, Bible prophecy. This
this testimony that we've just explored
together was sort of the the building
the launch pad into 25 more years or 30
more years. How many more years of
evangelism since the professor days?
Well, it's it's 38 years that I am into
evangelism.
>> Okay. 38
>> 15 of those were back in the university.
>> Well, I was going to ask Martin, you you
know Walter well. You've heard this
testimony. What's your reaction
>> to his testimony? Well,
>> yeah. Yeah. React to two hours of
content, Martin.
>> That's fine. It gave me a lot of um um
hope and it also gave me a lot of
confidence in the things that when we
were uh look uh my background was
completely also different from what
where I am now. And um just another
thing that you you briefly mentioned,
but I think you can just go on with that
a little bit. Was the time when um the
when you said the um priest called you
after that? Did you have still have the
manifestations going on in the house?
>> Well, after that when the priest called
us, I realized that I must make a
decision. I'm sitting on a fence.
And my issue at that stage was still the
Sabbath
because I wasn't totally on board with a
short chronology, a six day creation,
and I wasn't going to be a hypocrite and
keep one day in commemoration of a six
day creation if I didn't believe it.
And then interesting thing happened.
This was while I was still at the other
university. While nobody really knew yet
that there was something going on in my
mind. I hadn't even presented that
lecture yet. When a secretary at the
university handed me a pamphlet, well,
it was actually more like a document.
And she said, "Would you please read
this out of the blue?"
And I took this document and it was a
document on the Sabbath day.
And for some reason I didn't have time
because I was involved in whatever some
research project with a student or
something. I didn't have time to read
it. So I gave it to my wife and I said
you go and find out what this thing is
about. And I gave it to her to read and
my wife read it. And the document was an
argument for Sunday.
Fascinating. So it argued why Sunday
should be the new Sabbath day. And my
wife studied the document which was
written for Sunday keeping. And she came
to the conclusion that it was wrong and
that Sabbathkeeping
Saturday was correct because she said
that all that they had was what Bishop
so and so said and what this theologian
said, but there wasn't one Bible verse
to corroborate what they were saying.
Whereas the argument for the Sabbath had
all the Bible verses on its side. So she
said to me she's not going to keep the
Sabbath which totally flabbergasted me
because I I wasn't there. She was
actually ahead of me on that issue. So
my wife on the basis of a document
written against the Sabbath given to me
by a secretary out of the blue had no
idea of any religious connotation
concerning me. Why would she give it to
me? And I gave it to my wife. And uh so
this tickled me pink and eventually when
through prayer
peace and calm resto was restored in my
home and the occult phenomena uh ceased
to exist.
I realized that you know before I'd gone
back to the Catholic church but now I
have to go to the truth.
So, who are those who keep the
commandments and hold to the testimony?
And so, I became a seventh day
Adventist.
And that didn't sit down well with very
many people. In fact, one of my
colleagues from university found me and
lambasted me for such a stupid decision
because
this sect or cult as he called it based
their their thinking on what a certain
LG White had said.
And I said to my wife, "Who is Ellen
White?" I'd never heard of her.
Scott, I was a baptized Seventh Day
Adventist.
They had given me Bible studies. The
pastors at the church at the Seventh Day
Adventist church had given me Bible
studies. Not one of them had ever
mentioned LG White to me,
which is very weird. I think maybe they
were afraid of me or something. I was,
you know, this weird guy from the
university and maybe they didn't want to
confront that issue. I don't know. I I
didn't hadn't heard about energy wide. I
was eating everything that was wrong. I
was told drinking alcohol and wine.
Nobody had told me that. That was not
biblical, etc., etc. I knew nothing of
any of that. And when this colleague
phoned me and said, you know, you have
this and he used swear words, cuss words
to refer to her. And I thought, you
know, such animosity.
There must be something interesting in
that. [laughter]
And then I remember the cult porter had
brought a box of books and maybe there
was something interesting in there. And
that's when we we put our hands on that
books and the first one I took out was
called Desire of Ages.
And uh jokingly now unfortunately the
one that my wife took out was called
Councils on Diets and Foods.
And we parallel read those two. And I
was convicted that what whoever wrote
that surely must have been inspired
because every single word was in harmony
with the word of God and just made the
word of God explode and become relevant
and some of the typologies that you
missed, they were brought out. It was
just an amazing journey for me and
getting to know this individual called
Jesus Christ who to me was before a very
vague individual
now became a reality
and uh she changed our lifestyle
and uh I didn't oppose her on the issue.
It was hard in the beginning but uh the
opposition we got towards that again
convinced me that it was right. So many
times that which was given to us to
oppose what we were thinking
uh confirmed us in what we are thinking.
So if if opposition becomes very
vehement then you must look into it and
determine what is this epo this
opposition all about. Is there something
that somebody wants you to neglect to to
ignore and therefore you have to do a
very thorough Bible study. So I started
studying clean and unclean foods. Why
are they unclean? Why are they why are
they clean? Why do you have all of these
laws that are now relegated to the trash
heap of Old Testament theology
and uh you know laws about uh
let's say uh behavior during uh the
woman's cycle etc etc why are all these
laws in the Bible and everybody ignores
them and being a physiologist and
working in the medical field I I started
looking into that and realized. But hang
on a second. People that adhere to these
these laws like sec like Orthodox Jewish
ladies for example, they don't have the
diseases of the western world. They
don't have endometriosis
or they don't have uh the viral cancers
that the that the rest of the world
have. And and why is it that if they
adhere to this this norm in the
scripture that they don't have these
diseases and then you get the verses in
the Bible, I will put none of the
diseases of the Egyptians upon you if
you will do these things. So I started
studying these things and introducing
them into my research programs and I
came to the conclusion that wow the
world has thrown away a treasure book of
knowledge.
In fact, the entire medical world's
modern hygienic uh approach is based on
somebody going back to the Bible and
saying, you know, if you're working with
dead bodies, at least wash your hands
before you you work with someone who's
alive before you transfer all kinds of
sicknesses. And so I started looking at
the Bible in a totally different light
and realizing that this was a body of
truth not necessarily written in
scientific language but scientifically
relevant to the core and it changed my
life. The book is the truth as it
stands.
>> Amen. The Bible stands. You know that's
that's really the theme. take away from
this whole testimony. I believe it it's
what relieved your family of the
oppression of the enemy was walking into
the truth. You know, Jesus is the one
that protects us and Jesus is the truth.
And so, we need to be founded in Bible
truth as we pursue that victory over
over the enemy. The Bible is what
brought you to a knowledge of the
doctrinal views that you hold today. And
the reason that you are a Seventh Day
Adventist today, those writings of Ellen
G. White are wonderful. I can testify to
that as well. They've really deepened my
experience with the Bible. And side
note, by the way, the book The Great
Controversy by Ellen G. White. Do you
guys know how many times she uses the
phrase the Bible and the Bible only in
that book?
>> Absolutely.
>> It's exactly seven times.
>> Seventh Day Adventists are people of the
the foundation of the Bible being our
belief system. And so I've really I I
also came into the church into the truth
not really understanding the role of LG
Wright and White and that there's this
prophetic gift in the remnant church. I
I was on the fence on that.
>> Uh but I was fully on board with what we
know the Bible teaches, including what
you got out of the Bible in the last
days.
>> You know, Scott, what what amazes me is
the Bible says, "Seek and you will find.
Ask and it will be given unto you." uh
the problem with the world is they don't
seek and they don't ask.
So when I said if you exist reveal
yourself to me he did that very day I
found that pamphlet that very day
and a journey started
uh if there's anything wrong with this
then show me that very day he answered
that prayer when I said what now I don't
have I don't have a means to support my
family and I've thrown my career in the
waste paper basket that very day he
answered that prayer. And so I can go
back and I can ask myself the question
when did God actually
uh intervene in my life? And I can say
from the beginning
>> from the beginning from the very first
questions that I asked in a religious
instruction class where as a young boy
10 years old I realized there's
something wrong with the system and
there's something wrong with the
portrayal of God. I didn't know God. I
didn't know what was wrong, but I knew
something was wrong. And I was on a path
to atheism.
And I went into the secular world and I
studied evolution. And I I became a
lecturer in evolution. My thinking was
evolution.
And uh I I taught it at the postgrad
level. I taught evolutionary theory. And
here I was being basically trained in
the wisdom of the Egyptians just like
Moses was
unbeknown to the fact that one day the
rug will be pulled out under me and I
will be told now go and tell this to the
world. Now how do you how do you
approach something like that if you
don't know the something like that? And
the trouble with the with the creation
books that I read is that they were not
written by scientists. They were written
by well-meaning
Christians who had embraced creation
and their faith was commendable and many
of their facts were true but they were
put in such a way that a scientist would
find them unacceptable. Let's put it
that way. So there was nothing really
wrong with the books. But the argument
is how how would you know? You haven't
been there. You don't know. But I know
the theory of evolution. I know it
because I lived it. It was me. And
therefore I could approach it the same
way. I know the occult world. I was
involved of it. I did out of body
experiences. I spoke to demon entities.
I interviewed demon entities. I was
aware of these things.
Therefore, when it was exposed to me,
couldn't I speak to a newager? Couldn't
I speak to people in secret societies,
having been uh not a member of a secret
society, but exposed to them, being
invited into those fraternities, dealing
with people who were in those
fraternities,
talking to channels, channels of Africa,
for example. I personally interviewed
them, they thinking that I was one of
them. Wasn't this something that God
could use for me to expose the
wickedness of the man of sin? So in
every parameter that I got involved
with, whether it was Bible prophecy,
whether it was occult societies, whether
it was secret societies, whether it was
evolutionism,
whether it was medical missionary work,
whether it was health reform, I was
involved with it in a scientific and in
a spiritualistic sense. And therefore
it gave me a measure of authority to
speak on the issues which sometimes
upset people that weren't so offay with
these things and didn't realize where
they came from.
So I have had to butt heads over the
years. But I know that God has used it
because many in that realm from secret
societies and evolutionists and
paleontologists have come out of that
world and embraced the truth.
Because if I could change from what I
was, then maybe there was something more
to it than just meets the eye. This
wasn't just a case of a guy
uh being struck by lightning and having
another opinion the other day. No, he
had to have a total change of mindset.
And if you could accommodate that and
intellectually
try and reason with them as to why the
alternative was more plausible than what
you believed before. It gave it gave a
certain ambiance to what was being said
and it gave a certain authority which I
wouldn't have had if I hadn't had those
experiences. So maybe God in his wisdom
and in his grace took care of us while
we were walking yet sinners.
He cared about us and died for us and
knew that he was going to open the way
in the future and they would you would
see the light. But you had to get to the
point where you say, "Show me the
light." Because God is not going to
force himself upon you.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, I asked Martin, "Do
how do I address the two of you?" He
said, "Walter and Martin, I feel like
you brothers are friends of mine now."
And in respect, Professor Vice, on
behalf of millions of people who have
been touched by your lectures, by your
evangelism,
deep appreciation for your service to
God, for persevering through those times
where the budding of heads needed to
take place and for clearly identifying
the Lord's hand in your life from the
very beginning. When did the Lord begin
to intervene to it was from the be and
listener viewer God is intervening in
your life today right now and has been
>> right though
>> this video is him speaking to you the
links in the description to learn more
about prophecy and about the themes that
we've been discussing time is short
those videos open your Bible pray to the
Lord and ask him like Walter did to show
himself to you and he will and that is a
promise us from God's word.
>> It's a prerequisite. Ask and you will
receive. Ask God. Challenge him on it.
Say to him, "Okay, if this is truth,
then show me." He will answer that
prayer.
>> Amen. Amen. It's been an honor to be
with the two of you. And to each of you
viewers, thank you for tuning in. I'm
Scott Ritzma. Continue to follow these
brothers at Clash of Minds. Watch their
What's Up Prof episodes and follow me
over at Belt of Truth Ministries on
YouTube. Thanks to our producer,
Christian Digital Network from likes to
lives changed. Scan that QR code and you
can follow them as well. God bless each
one of you.
>> Thank you, Scott. It was a privilege
talking to you.
>> It was. Thanks. Thanks, Walter. Thanks,
Martin.
[music]
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]